on parle à présent des aid se un
acronyme que vous avez peut-être déjà
entendu sans savoir vraiment ce qu'il
définit il s'agit des zones faibles
émissions toutes les agglomérations de
plus de 150 000 habitants vont devoir en
mettre en place avant le 31 décembre
2024 afin de réduire leur pollution
atmosphérique ces élèves vont limiter la
circulation des véhicules les plus
polluants un épineux sujet abordé lundi
soir lors du dernier conseil municipal
de la ville de Tours Clémence Dausque
majorité et opposition partagent le même
constat la loi a des feux est
discriminante vis-à-vis des plus
modestes d'ici 2025 une zone faible
émission de voir le jour sur
l'agglomération tour en gel un espace où
la circulation des véhicules sera
réglementée en fonction de leurs
émissions à particules fines et oxyde
d'azote solution changer de véhicule un
effort inadmissible en contexte
d'inflation pour Olivier Le Breton il
faut sauver la planète tout le monde est
d'accord pour dire que dans notre ville
de Tours il faut faire attention au
polluant évidemment aux voitures mais
moi je pense aussi personne qui n'ont
pas forcément beaucoup d'argent et qui
veulent elles aussi et elles ont tous
les droits de travailler dans notre
ville de Tours venir à Tours pour aussi
y faire des courses tout ça parce
qu'elles ont une voiture qui est un tout
petit peu ancienne qu'on leur supprime à
ce droit c'était inadmissible en effet
d'ici 2025 les véhicules est classés en
critères 3 ne pourront plus circuler en
Z et feux il s'agit des véhicules diesel
datés d'avant 2011 et 2006 pour les
véhicules essence passer à une voiture
plus propre n'est pas ouvert à toutes
les bourses et la majorité assure
vouloir éviter cette fracture sociale en
interpellant les institutions et l'État
on verra dans quels sont les modalités
d'application de l'étalement et puis il
va falloir qu'on trouve des moyens pour
aider ces populations pour changer de
parc si infinie on n'a pas le choix et
qu'il faut qu'il faut y aller mais là
aussi il faudrait que l'État se mobilise
et nous aide à financer le
renouvellement du parc automobile
l'échéance approche mais les discussions
ont à peine commencé un décret du
gouvernement de 2022 permettant de
demander des dérogations pourraient
donner plus de marge de manœuvre